next guys Luna Wong his website is out
so I had the proof of work to find him
he's a busy student here at Brick Lane
he's going to talk about syrup another
protocol that uses a symmetric bivariate
polynomials
okay hello everyone
I'm Luna and I'm a second year PhD
student working with Professor down at
UC Berkeley so today I will talk about
our new project which is a dynamic
immediate practive secret sharing scheme
namely trip and this is a joint work
with canario University so first let's
go through some motivation so the
centralization is widely seen as a very
important step in the democratization of
resources so this is strongly
facilitated by the rise of blockchain
systems in the past decade
so these blockchain systems systems are
used in various applications so the most
well-known application is cryptocurrency
some other sensitive applications
include Identity Management and voting
system
so a common thread across all the
applications is the requirement that the
users need to maintain their own private
key and this is not easy because his
report is that tab failing of
cryptocurrency is lost because of lost
keys so people turn to our alternatives
that they turn to store their keys with
centralized entities such as coin based
but this kind of centralization of keys
actually undermine the very
decentralized nature that defines
blockchain system
so our idea is that why not we like to
centralize our keys like other resources
so the Holub idea is we want to use
secure sharing techniques to distribute
the private key so although our original
intention is to a cigarette share the
keys our protocol actually can be used
in many other applications such as
private smart contracts managed
encrypted documents and stressful
credential insurance so first let's take
a brief look at cigarette sharing which
we have already gone through in the
previous slide but yeah so a secret
sharing scheme is actually composed of
two algorithm a share algorithm and the
recover algorithm so given a secret the
share ism outputs the secret shares and
the recovery algorithm input all the
civil shares and output the secret so
the two algorithms need to satisfy two
requirements so the first one is
correctness that the secret recovered
from secret shares should be the same as
your original secret thread and the
security requirements requires that
given less than tea secret shares it's
impossible for any people to distinguish
two cigarettes shares of two different
secrets and this indicates that the
secret share schemes actually have is a
threshold protocol you need at least key
of the secret shares to recover the
original secret
so maybe the most widely used the
secretary scheme is shemune or secret
sharing so the high-level idea is you
set the constant term of a polynomial as
you are secret and you evaluate the
polynomial on some other points and use
these points as your secret shares so
when you want to recover the secret you
just interpolate T points and recover
the polynomial and then evaluate on zero
to get your constant term which is your
secret so the threshold of the of
Shamir's secret sharing is the degree of
the polynomial plus one talked about
what she talked about the problem of
keeping the keeping recovering use your
secret and your opposing the same
problem actually I missed the previous
talk part of it so I'm not sure like
yeah but yeah I guess there's a
difference so okay I would try to look
at the video of the previous slides and
see if there's any difference so so very
intuitive
baby had his first paper encrypted with
Silvia and the night before the dark and
Joe Killian come up came up came and
said you know the result that you have a
damn dog had it a few years ago even at
Krypton Sun shines hell you didn't know
she was devastated he was a first few
years ransom he calls up Silvio I mean
Silvia is the master of everything okay
she starts to talk the following day
good ideas are worth repeating okay
yes thanks so much for the explanation I
like it
yeah well as to believes there are some
difference okay so a very intuitive
solution will be to directly apply
Shamir's secret sharing in the queue
management scenario so in this scenario
private key is share to multiple parties
using Shammi receiver sharing and you
need at least t plus one parties to
cover it to recover the secret so this
system provides two properties which is
very good the first one is security is
that the adversary needs to compromise
enough parties to steal the secret and
availability means the user is always
able to fetch his own key where he wants
because the adversary also needs to
compromise and - tea parties to prevent
the user from getting her own key
so then is a number of the parties in
the committee however here is a problem
because actually these two properties is
based on an assumption that the
adversary cannot compromise the deaf
parties in a committee infinite time
period because we never update the
secret shares however this is not true
in many scenarios for example if there
are some vulnerability in all the
servers about parties and the bursary is
able to compromise these servers in a
constant rate then this will break the
assumption and the system is no longer
so
or
so your honor to address this issue
people propose product a secretary so it
is defined based on the occupational
secret sharing scheme the difference is
these schemes
periodically refresh the secret so there
are two kinds of practice secret sharing
the first one is a static which means we
only update the shares but do not change
the members of the communities and the
other one is called dynamic practice
cigarette sharing which means we change
the community and the shares so the
assumption in the dynamic practice
occurring is actually changed to the
adverse we cannot compromise enough
parties in a fixed type period which is
much more practical
so with this intuition hand we choose to
design chirping practive dynamics extra
sharing of labor and this is a common
workflow of the name a proactive secure
sharing yeah so we assume a synchronized
communication channel that every message
center will be received within a certain
time period and there is some research
going on try to extend chirp to summer
synchronized channel but it's but at a
very young period so yeah that's a very
good question so the common workflow is
first you need some setup and the share
face like some decentralized the key
generation protocol the user can just
compute the secret shares at his own
computer and send to the parties you
want to share you know a security I
don't like TRS channel so the Assumption
here is the same as the previous slides
as the Rosary can only compromise up to
t minus one parties in the committee in
white pork but one common challenge when
you try to design a dynamic proactive
secret sharing scheme is when you try to
update the committee members you need to
hand off the sacred shares to the new
committee and in this phase actually
there are two committees where old
community when new committee as a
simultaneously exists and according to
assumption the adversary' can compromise
t minus one parties in each of them
which is 2 t minus 1 in total and this
actually exceeds the threshold and this
means the rostrum may be able to steal
or destroy the security in this handoff
phase so whenever you design a dynamic
practice acquiring you always need to
find a way to like go through this
problem so ensure what we use is a very
polynomial and the technique called
dimension switch to avoid this problem
so if you put life hotline oh yeah yeah
because the old committee is still there
you submit a request the old committee
okay always like give you the sacred
shares they have so during the handoff
is the hosting is still alive yeah but
during that period a Swami are
vulnerable so that's what we actually we
abstract that part and zoom there are
some security know between each node
between each pair of the nose yeah so
actually yeah that's very good question
so actually we have scheme to use
blockchain system as a p2p a
communication channel in described in
our paper so the high-level idea is that
so when you submit transaction in the
blockchain system it will be first be
stored in some memory pool and if you
well it's not accepted you can always
rewrite it so using this property you
can always send a transaction to
overwrite the previous one and send
another to overwrite the second one and
using this thing you can actually
transfer a very large message using the
existing blockchain system
yeah so okay so our solution to to solve
this problem is to use bivariate power W
and the dimension switch so so the cool
thing about better polynomial is if you
still see the constant term as a secret
so actually there are two ways that you
can share the secret so the first way is
you can fix y equal 0 and to share
seekers sharing along the x-axis and you
can also fix axes x equals 0 and share
it along the y axis and because the
highest degree of x and y can be
different so the threshold of the sake
of sharing is also different so if we
can find a way to switch between x and y
then we are actually switching between
two secret sharing scheme that have
different stress hold and the good thing
about this is because if we have such a
schemes actually we can switch to a
higher stress hold secret sharing scheme
before the handoff phase and the switch
back after the handoff phase and that
will solve the problem so let's see how
we can actually do this it's very yeah
so let's use agreed to represent
bivariate polynomial and this line is
the y axis and the vertical line is x
axis which is a kind of anti intuitive
but it's fine and let's say we use a 2/3
polynomial which means one threshold is
three and another threshold is four so
when we are not in the handle phase so
each party in the committee actually
hold the four points along the y axis
which means it's a threshold secret
sharing and oh it's not a straight razor
oh yeah I so sorry sir as health
secretary and when we want to do a
handoff the older part is the old
committee will send its secret share to
the new committee but rearrange the
ownership of the secret shares in this
way
so the new committee will hold secret
shares along the x-axis and because the
degree of x-axis is 2 then it's actually
actually a forced secret sharing yeah I
think I didn't make her so by this way
we implement the dimensional switch and
now we are good about the handle face
so after we do the dimensional switch
the next thing is we want to update the
sacred shares so the basic idea you know
1-dimensional is because the only term
matters is the constant term then it is
always good for us to add zero whole
polynomial to our original polynomial it
will change the secret shares but they
will not change the constant term so
this is a example so the original
polynomial is X square plus X plus 1 and
the practive polynomial is 3x squared
plus 5x and add them together we get the
updated polynomial and you can see that
change oh sorry
the constant does not change but the
secret share actually change so yeah so
by adding 0 polynomial we are able to
update the secret shares but ensure
because we use a bivariate polynomial we
need to extend this technique to a
bivariate case and it's kind of very
intuitive so there are two steps in the
bivariate 0 secret sharing so first of
all you need to do one this one
dimensional 0 secret sharing along the y
axis and each of the node will get its
own secret share here and then we do
shammiracle sharing or key on these
secret shares and this will generate all
the points on the grid which means we
are good now because we have a favorite
polynomial whose constant is 0
so actually the last step of the handle
phase is that we need to switch back the
dimension to the lower threshold secret
sharing scheme and we are done in the
handle phase however we didn't talk
about the security of the handle phase
what if there is some malicious party in
the committee and try to send some
incorrect share to other nose to corrupt
the whole protocol so our solution is to
use commitment scheme and some consensus
protocol and we actually we use
blockchain the paper to solve this
problem so the commitment scheme I think
most of you are familiar with it but let
me introduce it it's a cryptographic
primitive that allows one to commit to a
chosen value but keeping it secret and
the people as a person can review it
later yeah and we use a polynomial
commitment scheme called kzg in chirp
and it has a very good commitment size
complexity which is a 1 for any degree
polynomial so the whole idea of the
solution is whenever you want to send a
message some other know that you always
need to submit a commitment on the
blockchain and afterwards if something
goes wrong I'm sorry the everyone can
verify the share and the commitment to
see if you have send a share that is
different from your commitment and
people may ask that well if the
commitment is committed to our wrong
value so the commitment in high level is
is the secret to some number and using
the algebraic property of these things
we are able to verify some property of
all the commitments on chain for example
we are
to verify that all the commitments are
committed to values that sum up to zero
so if you want to submit wrong
commitments then you will also be caught
because of this thing so if every
verification goes fine then we are in
the optimistic path and everything runs
good but if some of the verification
feels then we will deviate to panic
paths so there are two kinds of passing
passing trip so if a normal verification
fails then we are in Hasmik pass a and
our solution is we will require the old
committee to do the handoff phase again
but this time besides the commitment you
also need to submit verifiable
encryption of the message you send on
chain and with this thing we are able to
find exactly which party is a malicious
party and expel it and do the whole
handoff face again
and recall that we use a commitment
scheme called kzg9r rapido Co so kids eg
required a setup phase and the setup
phase may fail so if the setup phase
fails and the other words we may be able
to make up some wrong value with the
same commitment as the correct value so
we also has a verification step for this
kind of failure called the state
verification and if this verification
feels then we will deviate to PES make
pass B and the solution we use to solve
this problem is just we will redo the
handoff phase but do not use kzg
commitment but paterson commitment with
some sacrifice in performance so here's
promised comparison with state of art
called the shots MPs s so the arching
complexity means how many parts we prove
down the block chain and off chain
complexity means how many parts we
transfer in the p2p Network and the
stress hold is a threshold of SiC
pressure
scheme so we can see that compared to
the optimist path of MPs s the origin
complexity is the same but often
complexity is is improved to o n square
so this improvement is due to two parts
the first one is we use kzg which has a
wanker minimum size well MPs as use some
own a commitment scheme and another
reason is we use bivariate polynomial
and dimensions which deal with a handoff
problem so MPs as they use some blinding
polynomial which requires them to
generate a blinding polynomial for each
of the node in the new committee which
will also increase a factor of Owen in
the total complexity and we also say
that threshold of the optimistic repairs
of chirpies is a half of the committee
size well shows is only able to
guarantee one third of the committee
size and we can see that even the
Passyunk pass we are no worse than the
present pairs of shorts MPs s did not ID
the communication assumption shoes
protocol was defined for a synchronous
communication power pack is partial
influence
setting oh yeah yeah yeah that's true so
what TURN RIGHT and bitey
oh yeah that's that but even a
synchronized situation they also have
this threshold right but probably the
few over I don't think that people are
synchronized version okay I see yeah so
our commitment so our statement here is
that if we apply the MPS as in the
synchronized version it still has this
kind of threshold and you need some
modification to change it to hub of the
community size so in this scenario we
are better than them but in a
synchronized version I'm not sure if we
can still achieve half of committee size
maybe we will be able to
yes thanks for pointing that and last I
want to talk a little bit about the
implementation evaluation so we
implement chirping around 2,000 lines of
code and we run the protocol on 100 you
see two instances we run into scenarios
the last setting we start all the
instances in one data center and in one
setting we start instances across the
world so differences in one setting we
can see the influence of the network
delay well in the land setting we will
more focus on the computation cost so
our first experiment mirrors off chain
communication cost and we can see it
perfectly conforms with the theoretical
analysis the short MP SS has olan for
all into four complexity and our has all
into to work block you know how much
time within how much time your things
will be a grid or block chain for your
numbers oh so just how many bytes you
put so this is the off chain complex
there will be something that would allow
chain right
oh yeah so the complexity on blockchain
is the same okay
these shoes of the mean blockchain base
construction yeah
so shoes assume there are some consensus
protocol right and we plot blockchain in
there and we use serum in the evaluation
so actually we achieve like 2,000 times
improvement on the off chain cost and we
also measure the latency of the two
protocols and we can see that in the one
setting our protocol only takes five
seconds to finish in the again 100 nose
well short MPs takes up to 12 seconds in
only LAN setting which means our
protocol is actually more fast in their
short MPs okay so here are some
important points I want to repeat at the
end of talk so the chirp is a turn
robust proactive secure sharing protocol
so by turn robust we actually mean that
we also change the size of Committee I
didn't cover that part in talk but
actually we can do that and the biggest
improvement of chirp is it achieves much
better asymptotic communication cost and
we implement chirp and in practice it
also performs good ok so that's
everything for this talk and if you have
any questions please
you can see our paper at CSS this year
or visit our website or send me an email
yeah
[Applause]
not technical crashing okay he is this
kind of personal actually used anywhere
in the world at the moment
yeah so we are seeking for real-world
deployment doctrine about this Peugeot
and there is a start-up bhakti in San
Francisco Colossus lab and actually they
are trying you to implement this
protocol a rock chain system my
internships there this summer and and I
think Morgan is also trying to find out
an option
some people are thinking of using it but
yeah because this because we sold was
taking like 12 seconds and instead a 95
seconds maybe I confuse and then appears
in that part so the two thousand forints
boost is on the off training
communication cost so remember the
theoretical can have set up all in 2.0
and two so as in Hampi has as they
envelope as they need to transfer about
particle paths in the p2p network and
also going to transfer like several
Macca pets okay that's our that's where
so was it the same ideal first of all we
also have mentioned yesterday
no sorry Katrina evil listen and I try
[Applause]